mark teason he's a fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute Karen
Tumulty opinion writer for The
Washington Post and Tom Bevan
RealClearPolitics co-founder and
president mark you know the importance
of presidents visiting troops in the
field in this context especially after
all that has happened after the Syria
announcement yeah what about this day
it's a great day and look all credit to
the president for making the trip all
credit to him for taking the first lady
which is a historic first and I'm sure
our troops really appreciate it having
her along as well and getting a chance
to meet her and it's always this is the
president's first trip to a combat zone
since he took office and it's really
important to do that because you get a
chance to present which always said I
need the advice and I would I'd kind of
deferred to my commanders on the ground
well now he had a chance to sit down
today with the commander's on the ground
and what I'm sure and I hope he listened
to them because I'm sure those
commanders on the ground told him is
that Isis is not defeated it's true the
president is right when he says we've
knocked the hell out of them but they
are not defeated and and he had to knock
the hell out of them because of the
precipitous withdrawal that his
predecessor Barack Obama made they had
about 700 adherents when Barack Obama
pulled out and they turned into tens of
thousands and took over a territory the
size of Ohio in Syria and Iraq right now
according to our military they have
about 30,000 fighters they had they have
lost their physical caliphate and
president doesn't Trump deserves great
credit for removing their physical
Caliphate but what they've done is
they've reverted into a classic
insurgency and according to our military
Isis as well as powerful today as they
were before the surge in 2007 so they
are not defeated yet and we have a lot
of work to do before they are Karen yeah
I think it was a great thing that he
went and I'm sure that the troops very
much appreciated it and certainly after
Christmas Eve with the more than a dozen
tweets it was interesting he was he was
relatively disciplined for Donald Trump
I think the only thing that really
marred it was when he kind of went into
campaign rally mode at one point where
he brought in his fights with the
Democrats and and those sorts of things
those are really not sort of the kind of
rhetoric that we are used to seeing
out of a president in this kind of
setting this sort of partisan sparring
taking it past our shores you know he
also said that he's not pulling US
troops out of Iraq which I'm sure is a
welcome news for the Iraqi Prime
Minister who's still dealing with issues
in his country about that Iraq
commitment take a listen to two former
officials I think the president's trying
to communicate that he is on top of the
national security decisions that he's
been faulted for recently certainly for
the Syria decision and it's good to see
that he's also on top of Iraq I think
the fact that the president has
demonstrated a commitment to Iraq is
really important because we still have a
lot of work to do there both on the
domestic political scene as well as
ridding Iraq of those terrorists which
are seeking to do them and us harm you
know and Tom the security was extremely
tight they had some kind of thought that
there was a breach heading over or that
they were being tracked Air Force One as
it landed in Al Asad Air Base and I
think that might have tightened things
even further they did not meet
one-on-one with the Iraqi Prime Minister
on the ground there was a phone call but
just being there and saying that the US
troops were staying is probably a relief
to the Iraqis I'm sure it is and and
also I mean I think it it shows Trump
look to Mark's point I mean there's been
some some discussion about whether this
is a wise move or not it's certainly the
pullout of troops from Syria it
certainly was something that Trump
talked about a lot campaigned on wanted
to do and he's finally doing it but I
think there's also reassurance that you
know Trump's not going to be shy if Isis
rears its head using using the troops in
Iraq as a base to go back in and you
know knock the heck out of and as Trump
would say so I think he absolutely is
going to be committed to to the fight
against Isis all right let's turn now to
the shutdown and where we are in this
standoff here is the president on
Tuesday and also his top economic
advisors I can't tell you whether
government's going to be open I can tell
you it's not going to be open until we
have a wall offense whatever they'd like
to call it I think
they understand what's happening they
want water security the people of this
country want border security you know
it's not a question of me and I'd rather
not be doing a shutdown so they might
miss a pay period because the
government's shut down but in the end
even if they aren't working then
Congress has decided to pay people for
the whole time and so in the end it's
not it's really just a sort of
short-term problem not a long-term
problem for government workers mark I
mean there seems to be backbone here on
the president's part and that worked
from Capitol Hill is that he is not
going to back down unless there's
significant movement on the wall of
border security or a fence or whatever
you want to call it I agree look I think
actually time is on the president's side
in the in this shutdown fighting here's
why Nancy Pelosi today made some snarky
comment about how his concrete wall has
become a beaded wall that's a sign that
the Democrats are not negotiating and
they're not taking it seriously the
president on the other hand has paid
Mick Mulvaney was on Fox News Sunday and
he said that they've made an all counter
offer to the Democrats for a lower price
tag that Fox News has been reporting
that it's 2.1 billion so president is
trying to compromise and come to it to
an agreement and the Democrats are
making snarky jokes and thinking they
have him on the run and not engaging
further for the short term he owns the
shutdown because he claimed the mantle
of the shutdown he said I want to shut
down the government over border security
but over time if he seems to be the one
Americans won't compromise on this if
he's the one who's compromising and the
Democrats are demanding absolute
surrender and then they're it's gonna
backfire on them because that's not what
the American people want and over time
as he keeps making if he can be
responsible and keep making concrete
offers that are that are concessions to
the Democrats then over time they will
start to own the mantle of the shutdown
so I think he's right to stick to his
guns and and be reasonable and make
reasonable offers
yeah I'm Karen we put up the pie chart
often about this particular shutdown and
what has been funded and what is still
really in doubt here and whether it gets
a deal and that is 25 percent it affects
the not yet enact
Bill's in the spending bills that's
still a lot of people potentially who
are affected as it could last into the
new year and this idea that this is just
a short-term impact and you know that
they will all get their back pay
the fact is for these government workers
their their mortgage payments still come
due their credit card payments still
come due so a lot of these people are
living paycheck to paycheck and also
there are a lot of federal workers
people who work for the government who
are contractors who who clean the
buildings who really are paid on an
hourly basis and those people will not
be getting back pay so for the people
who are affected and yes it is you know
a small piece of that pie chart but but
to say that these are temporary effects
and that it's like you know no big deal
as long as you get your back pay is
simply not true for people who do live
paycheck to paycheck right and to that
point what if the shutdown continues
into the new year this is an official
talking about that Kevin Hassett
lasts longer than December then all that
back pay that people would get for the
weeks of December would come in January
and so that would have a slight negative
effect on GDP in the fourth quarter and
a positive effect on GDP of the first
quarter now I guess I just don't see you
know that it's kind of rolling off of
them and and if that's the case then
eventually this negotiation is gonna go
the other way yeah we'll see how please
I mean right now this is sort of like
the first quarter of this thing and it's
not really people are on holiday they're
gonna be on holiday through the first
year but after the first year
pressures gonna get ratcheted up
Democrats are gonna come back Nancy
Pelosi is gonna put a bill in the house
on January 3rd to reopen the government
and and then they're gonna put the
pressure on Trump why won't you sign
this why won't you do this now there
won't be any border funding in that and
that's when the fight is really going to
heat up and we're gonna see who's got
the leverage and where the pressure
points are and whether Mark's scenario
plays out where the Trump can flip this
on them and say listen I'm negotiating
good faith you guys are not negotiating
at all so now it's your shutdown wolf
but but it is going to get serious in
about a week